please welcome rosario dawson and retta
oh i'm so happy to see you
it's so good to see you too hi rosario i
know you've moved
east kicking it in newark with your
boyfriend
yeah i'm a jersey girl now i didn't see
that coming
how do you like it i'm i'm learning
a lot of different jersey factoids to be
sure
you know jersey the home of saltwater
taffy
retta i'm so grateful because you
were kind enough to do the pilot of this
show
and we put on blindfolds and like had
fun
and did taste tests and just had a
really good time and it was such you
honored this show with your presence and
i i just
i owe you everything and i want to work
alongside of you
for life and i just love you and i thank
you and i'm so glad we're back together
here on this real show
and um you know rosario i have to tell
you guys
i i am so blown away by your podcast
it's amazing what you guys have done
this was kind of put together by a bunch
of different senators women
you know created a whole space you know
create a whole fund
and a whole committee for this to make
it happen so you know it was just about
trying
to be as prepared as possible for the
centennial
i think the production was amazing i was
i really was like
dang am i a part of that because i had
no idea how much was going into it
i think that you know you listen to a
lot of podcasts and some of it's sort of
really fun and meandering your guys's is
incredibly focused
it's so educational it's super
interesting i was wrapped
from the beginning i it hooked me and
i was just so excited to understand this
history
why was it so important for you guys to
do this
for me um one i
i was shocked at how little i did know
about the suffrage movement
and anything that can encourage more
people
to get registered and get out to vote
and and and understand the importance of
it
you know voting has a direct
relationship
of you know to what's going to go on at
your job
in your supermarket you know in your
your towns and your restaurants and all
of that that
made me say okay i don't like certain
things i
might want to have a say in it and
rosario you talked about your
grandmother
being your influence yeah she was
born and raised in puerto rico and um
and as
i say in the podcast you know she raised
me
with the understanding that just because
she spoke with an accent didn't mean she
think
that she would think with one and that
she had um
you know that she had a voice even
though she represented
a marginalized person according to you
know what she represented a paper
you know she was a mother of five single
mother my her daughter
um had a me at a you know out of wedlock
as a teenager you know so you know we
fit we fell into the statistics of
people that so often are marginalized
and what i loved about this podcast in
particular
was that it was starting to show the
history of how women had been voting
long before
the 19th amendment was ratified and that
there were a lot of women of color
who were still denied that right even
after it was
and i think this podcast helps to
elaborate just how many more people
are part of a history that has made it
possible for us to have the rights that
we have today
and that we have to stop marginalizing
them and discounting them from the story
and you said in the podcast rosario that
you look to history
sometimes in the present and that's
something i do
too because i want to understand where
we've been in order
to be more educated about where we're
going and
um i i'm so honored to speak about it on
the show
and you can go to our website and get
links to it
and i just thank you guys so much for
coming on the show and talking about it
hey before you guys go can you do us a
favor we wanted to try something and
you'll be the first people to ever do it
with us
okay our vff's our virtual friends and
family
uh it's called 15 seconds of fame and
they wanted to ask you a question
in 15 seconds that you would have to
answer in 15 seconds how do you feel
about that
all right okay great oh hi brandt
brant are you ready for your 15 seconds
of fame and your question
i am drew thank you perfect rosario
you're gonna answer first and then i'll
go to you reddit and the clock starts
now go
was that rio what was your first ever
job before you became an actress
uh i was a babysitter and a tutor
actually my very first job was working
on
sesame street your turn
my first job was i was a cash
cashier at a nickels which was
like a target perfect
okay i think that went okay i'm excited
and that was really fun and i hope
i get to get a 15 second answer because
i i i would not do well in 15 seconds
because i never know when to shut up so
this was so fun thank you guys so much i
really appreciate you guys coming on i
love what you're doing and
we're here to shout it from the rooftops
thank you so
much rosario and retta's podcast
is called and nothing less and before we
go to break i want to show you a clip
from a documentary i worked on
years ago that we spoke about that
helped start my
voting fire all right take a look can i
ask a question are you going to vote
this year why do we have the lowest rate
of young voters
give them a reason to vote
i have also come to believe that we all
passionately want to feel a part of
something
so that we are not alone and although
voting
is a very personal ritual it brings us
all together
in the most profound way